there's actually a bit of a gender
pattern which I think men really
struggle to know what they feel and how
they feel and if they can identify
anything into anger but but anger is a
superficial emotion it's almost like a
secular emotion it'll be a masking a
deeper hurt and then we'll explore with
courage and with openness and with
vulnerability safely what is underneath
that there will be hurt there that you
mind trying to protect you from and it's
easier to feel anger anger is very
empowering whereas hurt is very opening
or with often with females they know how
they feel or they're not sharing it
they're not truly sharing how they feel
to the person they love or sharing truly
what they're experiencing at work and
it's holding them back and eventually
though we reach a point where we're
thinking we're sickness we can't
continue anymore because the pain of not
connecting to our truth and expressing
Our Truth is too much
foreign